coinbase ceo says
regulation is one of the biggest threats
to crypto this is a cnbc interview here
that once again coinbase ceo brian
armstrong
said regulation has won the biggest risk
when it comes down to cryptocurrency
business we're very excited and happy
play
to play by the rules basically we just
ask that hey
we want to be treated on those level
playing field with traditional financial
services at the very be
at least and not have any kind of
punishment for being in the crypto space
his company is the first major crypto
business to trade publicly in the u.s
coinbase is profitable taking in 300 322
million dollars last year
an estimated 800 million dollars in
first quarter
revenue alone so even the guy
asked a question saying are you worried
about regulation it says regulation is
one of the biggest
risks when it comes down to
cryptocurrency business thoughts
well he said the two biggest risks were
cyber security
cyber security yeah that's right he did
say that and shout out to
everyone who's been eager to invest in
the ipo for coinbase and
something tells me there might be a uh
case study a study coming
but you know when i kind of first got
into the insurance industry well i've
been it for a few years everyone was
like the dol the dol and the regulation
and the regulation
and for my industry regulation turned
out to be a good thing uh for the life
settlement industry because when i
entered it in 2006 it was the freaking
wild west
so i guess my question back to you
because you have very strong opinions on
this is is regulation a good thing
is it a bad thing is it somewhere in the
middle where do you think the regulation
will lead
you know who's going to be um running
the show when it comes to regulation
i'm sort of just giving i want to get
your response on this who gives the
regulations yeah like just give
give the run down the pros and cons
powell exactly well
obviously the chairman fed the secretary
treasurer sec
anybody that wants about the tax
implications the irs we could do that as
well remember internet we used to have
no taxes on the internet internet tax is
a new thing when you used to sell stuff
on the internet you did not pay taxes i
don't know if you knew that or not
i might not know that years ago if you
sold stuff on the internet you didn't
pay taxes
until they came out with taxes on the
internet what a year
it's probably a decade ago when they
came out with taxes on the internet so
what are the pros and cons
can you pay attention please go ahead
keep going what are the pros and cons of
regulation of
tom what are the pros and cons of
regulation the pros and cons of
regulation
on uh coinbase well it's the underlying
crypto crypto okay well coinbase is just
is a market it's a marketplace yes but
if that which it is
marketing the uh individual
cryptocurrencies
there's an issue with them then it has
no business and so the regulation of
those things is what he's worried about
he's not worried about himself being
regulated as much as
hey i'm a marketplace i'm a buyer and a
seller and there's rules for that and
you know people have to you know to have
accounts everything protection of
privacy regulation for that
but now regularly dependent of what
correct correct he's basically running
like a robin hood for
that's what i called it last year
exactly
the pros of regulation on cryptocurrency
is that it is a new medium and i believe
that there's a lot we don't understand
and need to do
number one and number two we're also
actually
trusting the technology sector that the
privacy
and any of the things that can happen
underneath it
are working and so i i think there needs
to be
you know regulation underneath on all of
the people so don't worry about it it's
on the blockchain that's uh
well we don't know how do we know
do we have a do does the fbi have a
division that completely understands all
the ways that maybe you can manipulate
the blockchain
and cheat honest people probably not
secure probably not yet
so do we need regulation and laws to
make sure there's guard rails and
everything on there to protect people
that are investing in it
absolutely that's the pros of regulation
the cons of regulation is
this is politicized and the fiat
currencies are threatened
and so inside oh we need to regulate it
for the safety
and the you know the integrity of the
system and to protect the individual
investor
there's also political things out there
there's a lot of people that don't
particularly
you know want this to be competing with
currency bases so
i know you know you know what's got to
be frustrating is to the billionaires
who became billionaires through business
and the stock market who don't believe
in crypto
they got to be very upset right now
because a lot of those guys are getting
threats from guys who are skaters
who are about to be billionaires and
like dude you're not a qualified
billionaire and they're about to become
billionaires
many of these guys are about to become
billionaires yeah and the billionaires
who
went to the right schools they have the
right last names they did it all the
right way and they got picked up and
they made all them
nothing wrong with them more power to
them i salute a lot of these
entrepreneurs
but it's got to be tough for some of
these guys to say they were so
anti-crypto i've never been anti-crypto
i've been
it's regulation is eventually going to
get you because i know how politicians
work when you become too powerful you
know it's really interesting you say
that
but i see history repeating itself here
and i know crypto's got a lot of
regulation there's a lot more to it and
it's competing with currency systems yes
but there were media barons that were
saying the same thing about jerry yang
at yahoo and about steve case at aol
oh these guys have just gone through
zero to six true
and now they're media guys so true oh
gosh they didn't do it the way we did it
we built this thing up
channel by channel walter cronkite and
all this stuff and these guys come out
of nowhere in their billionaires
absolutely
same thing is happening today it's tough
it's tough when you get a newer wave
that's coming in that's like
right now how many people are right now
saying steph curry is the most exciting
player in the league
a lot a lot they're saying he's the
modern-day michael jordan ahead of
lebron james
that's what's trending today he's the
most exciting player they're not saying
he's the greatest
they're saying he is the most exciting
player in the league right now like
michael jordan how come they're not
saying lebron
because lebron is not as exciting steph
curry why lebron's big 6-8 jumps 41
inches he can dunk he's like a
linebacker 285 pounds
steph curry is bitcoin because steph
cree's the way of winning his shooting
eleven threes yesterday in 29 minutes
scoring 43 points in the night before
scores 50 points makes
10 threes passes will chamberlain but he
doesn't dunk the ball
no it's a very different game and
attention's going in a different
direction with crypto
and some of these guys that have forever
been the main guys going on cnbc msnbc
all these play they're like a little bit
less being called upon than the other
guys
so make a prediction because you've been
talking about regulation regulation
regulation
for bitcoin and crypto for a while now
where do you see this going
i think if uh if you study history
politicians eventually figured out a way
to create laws
to impose themselves on those who
are entrepreneurs and different thinkers
that's correct they eventually figure
out ways to create laws against them and
guess what entrepreneurs typically find
a way to do
entrepreneurs and innovators typically
find a way to go around them yeah of
course
and this happens this is a battle that's
going to happen over and over and over
and over and over again
and guess what majority people hate in
the world do majority of people love
billionaires and millionaires or do
majority people
hate them more on the latter more on the
latter so what
what do they vote for do they vote for
leave them alone and let them keep
creating or do they vote for
hey do whatever you can to create more
restrictions for them
and that is that is sort of the
fickleness of the average the fickleness
of the
of the mob goes like this they cheer for
you as the underdog
but if you win the game and host the
trophy now they don't like you
the guy says give people give k.d some
love it's tough to give
nets some love man i'll start going in
what i was looking at
pat i'm sorry case study i know you got
a coinbase case study coming up but we
have a coinbase case study that we did
two years ago
so go back and check on that we're going
to do a follow-up on value by the way
kai told me yesterday i showed the text
to you kai told me yesterday or disney
case studies the best one he's ever seen
and i came out yesterday we watched your
ducati case study last week on the drive
to miami thank you very much i
appreciate that where do you see
if regulation does come in where do you
how does that affect the price of
bitcoin specifically
that's a great question it depends what
kind of regulation they impose
but to be honest with you i don't think
by a lot i don't think by a lot i
don't think regulation will affect i
think crypto's going i think crypto's
going
i think crypto is going to go and do
what it's going to do but regulation is
going to come
some parts of the sector of crypto is
going to take a hit i don't know which
one it is right
because you have to think about how will
they regulate how from what angle will
they take it to be a pain in the butt
for
the crypto community what angle will
they take
what angle will it be no one knows
well and you know it all comes back
around again i mean that the banking
banking is here to make money loaning
money right the core of banking
makes money doing that nicola just
commented right and i gave five bucks
saying regulations are coming ripple is
on a lawsuit right now with sec right
now this will be good
for the entire space keep an eye on it
there you go yep go back to 2008 right
what was the problem in real estate
qualification standards were too
low right neenah no income no problem
right
and um now you have
real estate prices are even higher than
what they were and the interest rate is
a problem but no one's talking about
there's also the adjustable interest
rate sitting at two and a quarter
to start what does it take to double
that five
that's not a big jump for interest rates
but that would basically
double those mortgage payments and yet
they were saying oh we've cleaned the
whole thing up the qualifications are
different everything no
you know people are being qualified
still on the front end the argument on
adjustables is they're qualifying people
on the front end the payment on the
front end
not the payment for the potential and so
you're you're
you follow that you let the back end
ratios be way too
heavy on the adjustable mortgage on the
starting point and you don't say
listen i'm going to qualify for this
based on the starting point
plus a point and a half that's what i'm
going to qualify you remember they were
talking about we're going to do all
these things make it safer so people
can't accidentally get into bad
mortgages
wrong the banks want to give up
mortgages they want to loan them out
and we may not be doing nina but we've
had other ways that we are out there
loaning money and as your point is
capitalism finds a way
the market finds a way did you see what
peter thiel said about crypto and what
uh he said about china
yeah he said it's an enemy and it says
and they're in bed with russia and china
kind of thing
yeah who's in bed say it again yeah i'm
paraphrasing but peter thiel said
continue in that because i only saw i
scanned it i did not dive in yeah he
he was uh he was saying china is gonna
use crypto
in a way to uh uh bring the fiat
currency down in the u.s
to manipulate the fiat currency to bring
it down in the u.s they're going to use
crypto to do that go ahead
and remove the dollar as the reserve
currency so actually trying to attack
that yeah a billion percent believe
vagina would want to do something like
that yeah so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye